sur le métro aérien du pont birhakeim
Jean-Paul Belmondo cascadeur téméraire
police allégeant de Superman et de
superstars
le succès indéniable de l'association
Verneuil Belmondo explique peut-être
pour quelle raison les esprits chagrins
suspectent parfois ses saltimbangs d'un
nouveau style d'être doublé d'hommes
d'affaires redoutable et de pratiquer un
cinéma facile à ses critiques
ouvertement formulées Henri Verneuil et
Jean-Paul Belmondo ont répondu avec
beaucoup d'aisance
on dit facilement en hivernage chez
quelqu'un qui ne prend pas de risque il
fait des films à succès avec la vedette
énorme type Belmondo on a des cascades
des films à grands spectacles mais où
est le message
mais monsieur Goldwin a dit que le
message c'était bon pour les PTT ceci
étant dit je prends pas de risque je
crois que j'en prends beaucoup plus que
les autres parce que plus les moyens
qu'on vous donne plus le budget et élevé
et plus vous prenez de risque et il
n'est pas dit du tout parce que vous
prenez une vedette et que votre budget
est fort il n'est pas dit du tout
coffret du succès
sur le métro aérien du pont Bir-Hakeim
Jean-Paul Belmondo cascadeur téméraire
police allégeant de Superman et de
superstars vous représentez
cet acteur super payé super connue super
courageux vous devez Superman
[Musique]
je voudrais bien être super maintenant
je crois que personne n'est Superman
parce que
je suis comme tout le monde je veux dire
même quand je fais je pourrais être
surpris et comme vous dites je suis
comme tous les acteurs on est à la merci
d'un échec de toute façon et puis
courageux merci d'un mauvais matin aussi
on peut avoir une angoisse
c'est ce qui est bien d'ailleurs parce
que si j'étais persuadé d'être justement
comme vous dites la plus fort le plus
tôt je m'ennuierais dans la vie donc
regarde ici hein de Monsieur Belmondo
trois monsieur Moissac 4 monsieur
Belmondo qui dit lâche le
et vous ça voilà allons-y
on fait un film on fait un film comme on
a envie de le faire
et puis on attend
puis on regarde le public le public
je dis bien et je le mets entre
guillemets le public quand on veut être
un peu plus péjoratif on dit le grand
public et quand on veut être encore un
peu plus péjoratif on dit le gros public
le gros public c'est celui qui rapporte
le plus de sous
attention s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît ne faire que des films qui font
penser c'est embêtant même les gens les
plus intellectuels de temps en temps ont
envie le soir d'aller se distraire et de
pas se prendre la tête à demain
venez absolument pas envie que l'on dise
de moi que je suis un metteur en scène
ceci ou cela sache vous donne ma parole
d'honneur
il y a longtemps que j'ai pesé le poids
de ce que cela signifie ce qu'on dit de
vous et le mal qu'il faut se donner pour
qu'on le dise ça de vous et j'insiste
là-dessus parce qu'il faut se donner
beaucoup de mal il suffit pas seulement
de faire le film encore faut-il le
déclarer partout très haut passé sa vie
à déjeuner avec les uns et les autres
pour leur faire croire qu'on est se
metteur en scène dont on dit que
[Musique]
je me fais rêver moi-même des fois je
joue des peut-être des choses comme ça
qui me font qui m'amusent mais jouer
Belmondo dans la vie je le garde pour
moi qu'est-ce que vous êtes dans la vie
monsieur gentil ou agressif ou si je
vous le dise ça serait terrible ça va
être censurer parce que à vous voir
comme ça je trouve que vous avez l'air
d'un bon jeune homme j'avais l'air très
gentil
vous ne vous forcez pas des fois être un
peu méchant
naturellement et des fois je suis gentil
naturellement ça va
et voilà c'est tout
je raconte des histoires
qui m'amusent qui me plaisent en
espérant que ça plaira aux autres par
exemple dans ce film peur sur la ville
je me suis fait peur un me racontant
cette histoire j'ai eu peur j'espère
pendant ce film communiquer cette peur
et puis faire sourire aussi de temps en
temps et puis et puis intéressé aussi et
puis si je suis arrivé à faire tout ça
c'est déjà énorme
[Musique]